Since taking the clear histamine scavenger, I have been having more loose bowel movements, so loose bowel movements.
Is this normal with this product? Also, I'm taking clear iron, so clear iron would not be causing the loose bowel movements.
It's probably if it is something you're taking, it could be something in the clear histamine scavenger, and taking anything that is possible.
Maybe it's helping you flush things out, helping you detox, making me think this is why I can't gain weight, whatever it goes right through me.
Yeah, we don't want that to be the case.
So I would say back off of this, the clear histamine scavenger is not the key component for anybody's cancer.
So I would just stop the clear histamine scavenger for a few days and see if this changes.
And keep in contact with me because you never want to be like eating food and then having to run to the bathroom and you just lose it.
You're not retaining your nutrition long enough for you to absorb enough calories and nutrients from that.
And yes, that can be unhealthy for a person and you can lose weight or fail to gain weight.
So just stop this. I went highly doubt that it's the iron.
If it is a product between these two, I did not look at this person's protocol, but if it is one of these two products, I would definitely say it's the clear histamine scavenger.
I just stop it for a few days, see if this calms down again.
Then I would just stay off of it for maybe a week and then maybe just go on one a day and see if that bothers you and play with your dosage like that.
And if you stay in contact with me because we don't want you to be having such loose problems that you're basically not absorbing your nutrients.